Я зараз спілкувалася з одним підрозділом
своїх підопічних вони зараз намагаються
витягнути тих хто вижив з тих трьх00тих
яких вони залишили і в них немає зв'язку
ми зараз вигрибаємо з волонтерами всюди
тільки можемо гроші щоб купити рації
щоби у них був зв'язок який мали би
забезпечити те саме Міністерство оборони
го верховний головнокомандувач чи різні
служби логістики ну їм Я не можу
подзвонити і цього сказати де до холяри
ра
Тому що ті хто забезпечують зв'язок
взують комбрига комбриг взує хлопців А
рацій так і не буде тому що амбіції
треба показати що хтось важніший тому
насправді найбільше вірять і хочуть
вірити в перемогу це наші військові які
хочуть повернутися додому